[Música]
a veces no hace falta explicarlo como
ante una obra de arte te quedas pegado
yohji yamamoto de 78 años presenta en
parís al igual que sus homólogos
diseñadores de moda su colección
prêt-à-porter para el verano 2022 y es
jubiloso las modelos desfilen al ritmo
de la música tocada interpretada por el
propio yohji yamamoto una versión de
mckinnon gestor de pop team
[Música]
pero este sabio japonés no es solo un
espíritu creativo libre de toda
restricción
que ha experimentado esta vez
esta vez de ese cabello
básicamente un mensaje deja de hablar
del calentamiento global
pasemos a la acción entiende
así
dejemos de destruir pensemos con el
corazón este es mi mensaje y es un
mensaje fuerte
tomando partido mirando el mundo de otra
manera la moda ya no duda en hablar de
las cosas que enfadan a la gente en esta
película experimental de la diseñadora
francesa marín ser el mensaje es claro
dejemos de lamentarnos como ratas
egoístas atrapadas en la trampa de las
ciudades contaminadas recargamos las
pilas en familia en el empleador campo
marín ser que dirige una nueva empresa
independientes no está sola en sus
esfuerzos por salvar el planeta por
todos los frentes desde que fue nombrada
al frente de la dirección artística de
dior en 2017 la italiana maría grazia
chiuri ha llevado a la casa a la era del
neo feminismo
a lo que los anglosajones llaman la
mirada femenina que en francés se
traduce como regla fémina
y es increíble es increíble como las
mujeres ahora tienen lo que se merecen
podemos hablar de ello más abiertamente
está bien
esto es obviamente algo bueno esto es
algo que debería haber ocurrido hace
mucho tiempo en la moda y me encanta que
maria grazia nos acompañe con zapatos
planos
es más fácil cuando uno quiere escapar
desde el punto de vista financiero es la
mirada femenina compatible con los
negocios
mira todo es compatible con el negocio
siempre que la prenda y todo lo que
aparezca el público esté hecho con el
cuidado la pasión y la calidad de diosa
kali tedio
maria grazia tiene una mirada muy
particular sobre la diversidad siempre
ha defendido los derechos de las mujeres
el feminismo
y desde entonces yo diría que hay un
feminismo militante
así que toleramos todas las formas de
feminismo la sexualidad y creo que eso
también es un poco de la era moderna
creo que es anti moderno oponerse a
ciertas miradas a ciertas expresiones de
la sexualidad expresión de sexualidad
para el próximo verano maria grazia
chiuri ha recurrido a los años 60 y más
concretamente a un diseñador poco
conocido por el gran público pero que
revolucionó la casa de moda durante unos
30 años tras la muerte de christian dior
marc bohan
fue un momento en el que la generación
más joven rompió las reglas y rompió con
el pasado no hay que olvidar que marc
bohan en 1960 introdujo el slim fit en
diop lo que supuso una verdadera ruptura
con el universo de la alta costura
manteniendo el nivel sodio a veces se
recuerdan más a otros diseñadores pero
bojan fue muy revolucionaron la historia
de dior era muy decadente incluso dentro
de la casa
marc bohan ya tenía una mirada femenina
en la moda hay siniestros y disgustos
sin conexión hoy creo que sí porque
estaba en contacto con mujeres como
nikki the sun page
mujeres como son ya del lunes es que me
hubiera gustado conocer
y su visión de la moda fue diseñada para
la nueva generación
introdujo el prêt à porter con migliore
introdujo el deporte en dior obviamente
no el mismo tipo de deporte que pensamos
hoy también introdujo babies your
inculcó una actitud completamente
diferente en la historia de la marca
los maniquíes se mueven en una
escenografía diseñada por la artista
feminista romana a nava para ti aquí
utiliza los colores y patrones de un
juego que inventó en 1964 el juego del
absurdo y del sinsentido
[Música]
señor arnaud y puedo hacerle una
pregunta sobre la mirada femenina de
maria grazia
creo que ese espectáculo fue
absolutamente magnífico
y hay algunos para los que la mirada
femenina siempre ha formado parte de sus
vidas isabel marant acaba de confiar a
su antigua mano derecha tim baker las
riendas de su colección de prêt à porter
como se creó hace mucho tiempo ya no
sabemos cómo lo hicimos porque hemos
hecho otros dos desde entonces
exactamente
[Música]
nos inspiramos mucho en las fotos de
hans forest un fotógrafo alemán estrella
de los años 80 y 90 que hizo un montón
de fotos preciosas para la revista el de
estas chicas súper deportivas y
saludables en la playa y ahí vino una
gran inspiración del mar y del sol
todos los colores nos inspiraron de
hecho para hacer esta paleta de colores
degradados que se ve en el espectáculo
esto es realmente lo que representa para
nosotros
pues somos mejores como estilistas que
como cantantes eso es cierto está claro
[Música]